This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客。百分之二。这就是当电梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在这样一个奇妙的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后变得更快乐、更有成就感、更健康。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。其中“2”的英文是T-W-O。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子交往过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我一定要做他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。听听好姐妹们的劝告。相信我，宝贝。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎收听《回首过往》播客。对1979年来说，那对我是个重大时刻。84年对我也意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首过往》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难成长》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯。这个节目探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方进行都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，你就非得这样做。请在AHA Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长》。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode, back for another topic. And today, back for another guest episode. I love doing these every now and again. And I'm super selective with the people that I bring on because I want them to really have something to say about the 20-something experience about what it means to be, you know, growing up during this time and at this age and during this decade. And I feel like one of the main experiences a lot of us have, one of the universal 20-something experiences is feeling incredibly behind and incredibly lost. And today we are bringing on someone who has spoken a lot about
大家好，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活改变和过渡，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听新的一期节目，探讨新的话题。而今天，又迎来了一期嘉宾访谈节目。我非常喜欢隔三差五地做这类节目。而且我对邀请的嘉宾非常挑剔，因为我希望他们真正能对二十多岁的经历发表一些见解，谈谈在这个时期、这个年龄以及这个十年成长意味着什么。我觉得我们许多人都有的主要经历之一，也是所有二十岁的人共同经历的一种体验，就是感觉自己远远落后，而且极其迷茫。而今天我们请到了一位曾深入探讨过
this, who has written numerous books about this experience. Dr. Meg J. Thank you so much for joining us. It's my pleasure, Gemma. I'm so glad to be here. So if you don't know who Meg is, you've definitely heard of her work. She is the author of The Defining Decade, one of my all-time favorite pieces of nonfiction. Thank you. Yeah, so I am a developed, well, I was saying, I love the title of your podcast because that's my whole life. I'm a developmental clinical psychologist, and I specialize in 20-somethings, which is a thing. It wasn't a thing. 20-year-old. years ago when I started, which we could discuss that later too. But, you know, it's a very unique developmental moment. It has its own unique challenges, its own unique solutions. And so that's
这个话题、并围绕这段经历写过大量著作的人。梅格·杰博士。非常感谢你加入我们。这是我的荣幸，杰玛。我很高兴能来到这里。如果你不知道梅格是谁，你一定听说过她的作品。她是《决胜二十多岁》的作者，这是我历来最喜欢的非虚构作品之一。谢谢。是的，所以我是个发展……嗯，我刚才在说，我喜欢你的播客名字，因为这正是我的全部生活。我是一名发展临床心理学家，我专注于研究二十多岁的人，这确实是一个专门的领域。20年前我刚开始时可不是这样的，对此我们待会儿也可以讨论。但是，你知道，这是一个非常独特的发展时期。它有它自己独特的挑战，有它自己独特的解决方案。所以这就是
what, you know, all my days and all my books are about. So what exactly drew you to really thinking about people in their 20s? I think it was a natural inclination for me. I started this podcast as someone in their 20s. I'm still in my 20s. What was the fascination for you with this, with this decade? Yeah, so I, believe it or not, I have been specializing in 20-somethings for 25 years. So maybe for like roughly your whole life so far. And so when I started doing that, I was actually in graduate school at UC Berkeley. I was getting a degree in clinical psychology and I was studying something called adult development. And when you say that to people, they're like, what? What's adult development? I thought adults were already developed. And, you know, adult development is,
我所有的日子和我所有的书所关注的内容。那么，究竟是什么吸引你去真正关注二十多岁的人呢？我想这对我来说是一种天生的倾向。我开始做这个播客时正处于二十多岁。我现在也还在二十多岁。你对这个十年有着怎样的迷恋和兴趣呢？是的，所以，信不信由你，我专注于研究二十多岁的人已经25年了。所以也许差不多就是你目前整个人生那么长的时间。当我开始做这个的时候，我其实正在加州大学伯克利分校读研究生。我攻读的是临床心理学学位，当时我正在研究一个叫作成人发展的东西。当你对别人说起这个时，他们的反应是，什么？什么是成人发展？我以为成年人已经发育完全了。而且，你知道，成人发展是，
is if you look at a 20-year-old and you look at 100-year-old, adult development is all the stuff that happens from 20 to 100. But when I started studying adult development, most of what was done there was about, you know, midlife crises or, you know, the elderly, or, you know, maybe it was, you know, the child rearing years. But there really hadn't been much of anything done on the 20s.
如果你看看一个20岁的人，再看看一个100岁的人，成人发展就是从20岁到100岁之间发生的所有事情。但当我开始研究成人发展时，其中大部分内容都是关于，你知道的，中年危机，或者是老年人，或者，你知道的，可能是抚养孩子的年代。但真的还没有多少关于二十岁这一时期的研究。
And we can talk about this more in a minute, but it had been somewhat recent that the 20s were sort of their own developmental moment. I mean, they're really, if you think about it, they're nothing like the teen years. They're not that like the 30-something years and beyond. They're really their own thing. So I was sort of discovering this along with a lot of research about all the amazing developmental things that are happening in our 20s. There's more change between 20 and 30 than any other decade in adulthoods.
我们待会儿可以多聊聊这个，但在某种程度上，二十岁自成一个发展阶段还是比较晚近的事。我的意思是，如果你仔细想想，它们和十几岁的青春期一点也不像。它们和三十多岁及以后的岁月也不大一样。它们确实有其独特之处。所以我也是在一边进行这方面的研究，一边了解到许多关于我们在二十岁时发生的神奇发展变化的。20到30岁之间的变化比成年期任何其他十年都要多。
And I was living in a college town, right? So I was inundated with young adults and 20-somethings who were sort of, you know, my first clients, guinea pigs and all this. So it just, and I had just finished my 20s. So it just felt like there was so much there. It was really where all the action is and no one was focusing specifically on that space. And one of the ways I figured that out was a lot of people would come to my office and ask the same questions. I would tell them the same things. and I thought, you know, I need to be able to recommend a book for people.
而且我当时住在大学城里，对吧？所以周围到处都是年轻人和二十多岁的人，他们可以说是，你知道的，我的第一批客户、小白鼠以及诸如此类的人。所以这只是……而且我刚过完二十多岁。所以感觉那里有太多的东西了。这真的是所有行动发生的地方，却没有一个人专门聚焦于那个领域。我发现这一点的方式之一是，很多人来到我的办公室问相同的问题。我会告诉他们相同的事情。然后我想，你知道，我需要能够为人们推荐一本书。
So I went into the bookstore looking for something back when people did that. And there was nothing. It was like the girlfriend's guide to your 20s, you know, maybe. There was just some couple of fluff projects out there. So I thought, wow, this is, you know, an untapped need that there's this period of time, which is very unique and people aren't really talking about it and focusing on and specializing it. So I started doing that and I have never looked back. I've never wanted to do anything else.
于是我走进书店寻找相关的书，那还是人们会去书店的年代。结果什么都没有。可能只有一些像《二十多岁好闺蜜指南》之类的书。市面上只有一些肤浅的作品。所以我想，哇，这是一个，你知道的，尚未被满足的需求，存在这样一个非常独特的人生阶段，而人们并没有真正谈论它、关注它并对其进行专门的研究。所以我开始做这件事，并且从此再也没有回头。我从未想过要做别的事情。
It is just to me the most important decade of life. It's also super difficult, which we can talk about, but I love it. It's so funny you were saying, like, you've been doing this for 25 years. It's like your career is a 20-something-year-old. Yes, yes, exactly. That's true. Yes, it's all about that decade one way or the other. So you said something in there, you were like, it's the most formative
对我来说，这简直是人生中最重要的一十年。它也超级困难，我们可以讨论这一点，但我很喜欢它。你刚才说的话太有趣了，比如，你已经从事这个25年了。这就好像你的职业生涯本身就是一个二十多岁的小伙子。是的，是的，完全正确。没错。是的，不管怎样，一切都围绕着那个十年。所以你在其中说了一句，你当时说，这是最具塑造性的一
decade, which I really agree, but it's also the most difficult. Like, it really exists in this vacuum between adolescence and what I sometimes refer to as like real adulthood, like in your 30s when all the things that you thought, you know, you would experience as an adult, maybe getting married, having children, buying a home. They kind of, for a lot of us, are happening a lot later. What do you think creates this real difficulty for a lot of? of us during this period. Well, it's, it's really that is that, you know, you're absolutely right. Adult milestones are now, you know, and I thought of adult milestones, I mean, you know,
十年，我非常赞同，但它也是最困难的。它确实存在于青春期和有时我所称的真正的成年之间的一个真空地带，比如在你三十多岁的时候，所有你以为自己作为成年人会经历的事情，比如结婚、生孩子、买房。对我们很多人来说，这些事情发生得要晚得多。你认为是什么给我们的这个时期造成了如此真实的困难？嗯，它，这确实是，你知道的，你完全没说错。成年里程碑现在，你知道的，当我想到成年里程碑时，我的意思是，你知道的，
figuring out your job and finding a partner, picking a city, you know, maybe getting a home, maybe having a kid. Like, that's all closer to 30 than to 20 now. And so in the 20s, it's just this big, wide open period of uncertainty. There's a lot more to sort of worry about than there is to hold on to do. The brain doesn't like that. So your mental health does not like that. And so it makes the 20s, you know, from where I'm standing, it's an amazing opportunity to work with people before they've made all their biggest decisions and to help them do that more thoughtfully, more productively, more happily. But it's from the other side of the room, the 20-something that I'm working with is living with more uncertainty than they will, really, at any
确定你的工作、找到伴侣、选择一个城市，你知道，也许买个房子，也许生个孩子。现在这些都更接近30岁而不是20岁了。所以在二十多岁的时候，这是一个巨大且完全开放的不确定期。比起你能把握住的东西，有更多的事情需要去担忧。大脑不喜欢这样。所以你的心理健康不喜欢这样。因此，从我的角度来看，二十多岁是一个绝佳的机会，可以在人们做出所有重大决定之前与他们合作，帮助他们更深思熟虑、更富有成效、更快乐地做出这些决定。但从房间的另一边来看，我正在合作的这个二十多岁的人所承受的不确定性，真的是他们在任何
other time of life. And that's what makes the 20s so hard is that it's probably the only time of life where you'll wake up in the morning and you think, gosh, you know, I don't really know where I'll live in five years, or if anyone's going to love me, or if I can pay my bills or where I'm going to work or if I can be happy. And that's really, really hard. And I don't think we talk enough about how hard all that uncertainty is. Well, let's talk about it now. Why is it that this uncertainty is so scary for us. Like how does that manifest in maybe our behaviors, even our mental health, the patterns that you see in 20-somethings?
其他人生阶段都未曾经历过的。这就是为什么二十多岁如此艰难，因为这可能是你一生中唯一会在早晨醒来时想，天哪，你知道的，我真的不知道五年后我会住在哪里，或者是否会有人爱我，或者我能不能付清账单，或者我要在哪里工作，或者我能不能幸福。这真的、真的很艰难。而且我认为我们对于所有这些不确定性到底有多艰难，讨论得还不够。好吧，那我们现在就来讨论一下。为什么这种不确定性对我们来说如此可怕？比如这如何体现在我们的行为甚至心理健康中，以及你在二十多岁年轻人身上看到的模式？
Yeah, well, I'll geek out briefly on brain stuff. But the brain interprets uncertainty as danger. And if you think about this evolutionarily, this makes sense. Like if you don't know what's around the corner, you're going to assume, you know, it's a bear, not, you know, it's a little bunny rabbit and things are fine. That's how we survive, that your brain is wired to keep you alive, not make you happy. So when there's uncertainty, we're going to interpret it as danger. We're going to feel stress.
嗯，好吧，我会简短地从大脑科学的角度极客一下。但大脑将不确定性解释为危险。如果你从进化的角度来考虑这一点，这是说得通的。比如，如果你不知道拐角处有什么，你会假设，你知道，那里有一只熊，而不是，你知道，是一只小兔子，一切都很好。我们就是这样生存的，你的大脑生来是为了让你活下去，而不是为了让你快乐。所以当存在不确定性时，我们会将其解释为危险。我们会感到压力。
We're going to feel anxious. Some people get sort of avoidant and depressed. Other people reach for substances or, you know, whatever they do to kind of manage that stress around, yikes. I don't know what's about to happen in my life. So it's not something the brain likes very much, but in the 21st century, it's this sort of staggering amount of uncertainty that 20-somethings live with. I mean, they live with it day in and day out for 5, 10, 15 years. And so that really takes the toll on people's well-being, on their mental health. Life does get better, and we can talk about that too.
我们会感到焦虑。有些人会变得有点回避和抑郁。另一些人则会借助药物，或者，无论他们做什么来应对那种围绕着“哎呀，我不知道我的人生接下来会发生什么”的压力。所以这不是大脑非常喜欢的东西，但在21世纪，二十多岁的人所生活在其中的是不计其数的惊人数量的不确定性。我的意思是，他们在长达5年、10年、15年的时间里，日复一日地生活在其中。所以这确实对人们的福祉和心理健康造成了损害。生活确实会变得更好，我们也可以讨论这一点。
But the 20s are tough. And I think we kind of maybe imagine or are told. that they're going to be this, you know, best years of our lives, but they're probably not and you don't even want them to be. You want life to get better as you go. I say that a lot, actually. I was saying it to someone before. Our 20s are when you have probably the least amount of money you will ever be making. Right. Your relationships are like up in the air. Everything feels so uncertain.
但二十多岁确实很难。而且我想我们可能曾想象过或者被告知，它们将成为，你知道的，我们一生中最美好的时光，但它们可能并不是，而且你甚至不希望它们是。你希望生活随着你的前进而变得更好。我经常这么说，事实上。我之前对某个人说过。在二十多岁时，你拥有的金钱可能是你一生中最少的。对吧。你们的关系就像悬在空中一样。一切都感觉如此不确定。
You're probably quite emotionally vulnerable. you don't probably like your job that much. And there is such an expectation of like, these are your best years. These are like, you better like really hold on to them because once they're gone, like they're going to be the source of all your nostalgia, all your memories. And I'm just like, is that really as good as it's going to be? I mean, let's hope not. No.
你可能在情感上相当脆弱。你可能不那么喜欢你的工作。而且存在着这样一种期望，即：这是你最美好的时光。这就像，你最好紧紧抓住它们，因为一旦它们逝去，它们将成为你所有怀旧情绪、所有回忆的源泉。而我只想说，这真的是生活能做到的最好状态吗？我的意思是，但愿不是吧。不。
I mean, that's what I say to my clients. If your 20s turn out to be the best years of your life, something has gone terribly wrong. because empirically, we know that actually, it may be hard to imagine in the 20-something, but life does get 30-somethings are happier than 20-somethings. And even old 40-somethings are happier than 30-somethings. Even the 50-somethings are happy. I mean, actually people do become happier, more grounded. Their relationships are better.
我的意思是，这就是我对客户说的。如果你的二十多岁证明是你一生中最美好的时光，那说明情况出了严重的问题。因为从经验上我们知道，实际上，在二十多岁时可能很难想象，但生活确实会变好——三十多岁的人比二十多岁的人更快乐。甚至四0多岁的人也比三十多岁的人更快乐。甚至五十多岁的人也很高兴。我的意思是，实际上人们确实变得更快乐、更稳重。他们的关系更好了。
They have purpose. They have meaning. They have sort of that emotional stability, that life security. So life really does get better. I'm not really sure how this kind of myth keeps perpetuating that, you know, your 20s are going to be amazing. I mean, there's some fun, cool stuff that goes on, but they're very hard. And all those things you mentioned of like, you're broke, you're moving to a new city, you don't have friends, new job, stressful. You know, your boss is, you know, stressing you out, et cetera.
他们有了目标。他们有了意义。他们拥有那种情绪稳定性，那种生活的安全感。所以生活确实会变得更好。我真的不知道这种神话是如何继续流传下去的，即：你的二十多岁将会是惊艳的。我的意思是，有一些有趣、酷炫的事情发生，但它们非常艰难。以及你提到的所有那些事情，比如你身无分文，你搬到一个新城市，你没有朋友，新工作，压力重重。你知道，你的老板，你知道的，让你压力山大，等等。
That's real. And, you know, the 20s are actually, I think, well for most people may be more difficult than they are sometimes that makes me hearing you say that because i i'm such an optimistic person right so right now i'm like my life is like the best it's ever going to be and so for some reason when people are like oh it gets better at 30 it gets better at 40 I'm like but what if it can't get any better so it has to get worse like what if i've got the inverse like what if this is what if i'm the exception like it but then i'm like Yeah, I find that hard to believe because the reason life gets better, it's not like just this random growth curve you're on.
那是真实的。而且，你知道，二十多岁其实，我认为，对大多数人来说可能比有时……听到你这么说让我觉得……因为我是一个非常乐观的人，对吧？所以现在我觉得我的生活是我有生以来最好的时候，因此出于某种原因，当人们说“哦，到了30岁会更好，到了40岁会更好”时，我的想法是：但如果它不能变得更好怎么办？所以它必须变得更糟。比如，如果我是反过来的呢？如果我是个例外呢？但随后我想，是的，我发现这很难相信，因为生活变得更好的原因，它不像是你正在经历的某种随机的成长曲线。
It gets better because you is a 20-something, whatever cool stuff you've built that you're super psyched about, and I'm very happy to hear that you feel like you have a great life, you're going to keep doing that. So you're going to build, you know, there'll be more relationships or deeper relationships. Your career is going to just get even better or your financial security will be, better and I mean that's sort of why it happens is that people I mean there's generally an upward trajectory in life and of course nobody knows what's going to happen tomorrow you know with the big stuff but you know in terms of people's individual lives I mean I love it if you feel like you've already built a lot of good stuff in your 20s because you're just going to keep building on that
它变得更好是因为你作为一个二十多岁的人，无论你建立了什么让你超级兴奋的酷炫东西——我很高兴听到你觉得你有一个美好的生活——你将继续这样做。所以你将建立，你知道的，会有更多的关系或者更深的关系。你的事业只会变得更好，或者你的财务安全会变得更好，我的意思是，这就是为什么会这样，因为人们——我的意思是，生活中普遍存在着一条向上的轨迹。当然，明天会发生什么谁也不知道，你知道的，关于那些大事，但你知道，就人们的个人生活而言，我的意思是，如果你觉得你已经在二十多岁时建立了很多美好的东西，我太高兴了，因为你将在此基础之上继续建设。
that's so um so reinforcing to hear the other thing that I um that actually a lot of people this is what I really want to talk about is like feeling like there is almost it's a bit of a race and feeling like it's a race to find the one. It's a race to buy a house. It's a race to have it all figured out. Why do you think so many of us feel this sense of just being behind during this decade? And what are we actually behind? Like behind what?
这太……太让人听了备受鼓舞了。另一件我……其实很多人，这正是我真正想谈的，就是感觉好像几乎有一场竞赛，觉得这是一场去寻找真命天子的竞赛。这是一场买房的竞赛。这是一场把一切都搞清楚的竞赛。你认为为什么我们当中有这么多人在这十年里会产生这种落后的感觉？我们究竟落后于什么？比如落后于什么？
Right. Well, that would be my question. Again, clients do say, but I'm behind. And I say behind what, behind who? You know, if you say behind what, there's usually a who. Well, so and so has such and such and I don't have that. Or, well, my parents had X, Y, and Z when they were my age, and I don't have that. So there's usually some person or some idea that someone's comparing themselves to.
对。好吧，那将是我的问题。再次强调，客户确实会说，但我落后了。我说落后于什么，落后于谁？你知道，如果你说落后于什么，通常都会有一个“谁”。“嗯，某某人拥有这样那样，而我没有。”或者，“嗯，我父母在我这个年纪时有X、Y、Z，而我没有。”所以通常会有某个人或某个理想，人们在拿自己与之比较。
But kind of the maybe maddening, but a truly wonderful thing about your 20s and beyond is you can't. There's just so many different paths you can't compare. Like when you were in school and everyone was in the same grade and you could compare your biology test with my biology test. You know, it's just not the way not everybody's taking the same biology test anymore. And, you know, we've all had different paths through life and are doing different things. So, I mean, you really can't compare two different lives. But we do. So usually when people say that they're behind, they feel like they're behind somebody or some ideal that they had.
但关于你的二十多岁及以后的岁月，也许令人抓狂，但同时也是真正美妙的一点是，你根本无法比较。有太多不同的道路，你无法进行比较。就像你在学校时，每个人都在同一个年级，你可以把你的生物测试和我的生物测试进行比较。你知道，这已经不是那种情况了，不是每个人都在做同一份生物测试了。而且，你知道，我们走过不同的人生道路，做着不同的事情。所以，我的意思是，你真的无法比较两种不同的人生。但我们还是会这样做。所以通常当人们说他们落后时，他们觉得他们落后于某个人或他们自己心中的某种理想。
But, you know, a lot of what I do is I like to say that education is an intervention. And so writing books and talking on podcasts, you kind of get the real information out there. And, you know, I remind people, well, let's look at, you know, the average age of some of these milestones. You know, in the U.S. anyway, average age of marriage is like 29. First kid is maybe 30. Home ownership is 35. and these are just averages. So the more career-driven or educated you are,
但是，你知道，我所做的很多事情就是喜欢说“教育是一种干预”。所以写书和在播客上交谈，你就能把真实的信息传递出去。而且，你知道，我提醒人们，好吧，让我们看看，你知道的，其中一些里程碑的平均年龄。你知道，无论如何在美国，结婚的平均年龄大约是29岁。第一个孩子大概是30岁。拥有房屋是35岁。而这些只是平均数。所以你越是以职业为导向或者受过更高教育，
these things can often happen even later because you're spending more time in school. So, you know, I think most of the clients that I have aren't behind, but I think they're worried that they will be because these are such long-form projects. And you can't see, like, I'm halfway there. You know, you don't know, right? You don't know that you may meet a,
这些事情往往会发生得更晚，因为你花在学校里的时间更多。所以，你知道，我认为我的大多数客户并没有落后，但我认为他们担心自己会落后，因为这些都是长期的项目。而且你看不到，比如，我已经走了一半了。你知道，你并不知道，对吧？你不知道你可能会在两年内遇到一个
partner in two years, but you can't really know for sure. So I think they worry that ultimately they're not going to get there. And it's interesting because I think that at the root of that is again, that uncertainty, that instability of like it just feels uncomfortable to not know, to not like in that lack of knowing, it's like such a capacity to catastrophize. I think when you don't have all the information, I know you talk about this. and your new book. Like there's such an opportunity there to make up your own answers, to feel like everything that could go wrong will go wrong
伴侣，但你无法真正百分之百确定。所以我认为他们担心自己最终无法达成目标。有趣的是，我认为这背后的根源依然是那种不确定性，那种不稳定的感觉，即不知道的感觉让人感到不舒服，而在那种“不知道”的状态下，有极大的倾向去将事情灾难化。我想当你没有全部信息时，我知道你会谈到这一点。在你的新书里。那里面有这样一个绝佳的机会去编造你自己的答案，去觉得所有可能出错的事情都会出错，
because you haven't seen the alternative yet, because you have no real conception of what it will mean to meet the love of your life, maybe tomorrow, to one day wake up and be in your own home and be super happy and not be dealing with work drama, friend drama, anything like that. And I just feel like how do we become comfortable with the in between, with the period between kind of dreaming and realizing where there is a lot of,
因为你还没有看到另一种可能性，因为你对于明天遇到一生的挚爱意味着什么，或者有一天醒来发现自己住在自己的房子里、超级幸福、不用再应付工作上的狗血事、朋友间的狗血事或任何类似的事情，根本没有任何真正的概念。我只是觉得，我们如何才能适应中间状态，适应介于梦想与实现之间的那个时期，在这里确实有大量的
yeah, just unknown, a lot of blank spaces for us to seemingly feel. Yeah, well, I love it that you mentioned catastrophic thinking. So as you mentioned, I have a new book out. Most people who are listening to your podcast have probably read The Defining Decade. I've got a new one coming out called the 20-something treatment. And it's really age-specific mental health. It's like personalized medicine, 20-something mental health. And one thing I address is it's been a chapter called How to Think, but it's really about catastrophic thinking.
嗯，完全未知的事物，有大量等待我们去填补的空白。是的，太好了，你提到了灾难性思维。正如你所提到的，我有一本新书出版了。听你播客的大多数人可能都读过《决胜二十多岁》。我有一本新书要出版，叫作《二十多岁治疗》。它是针对特定年龄段的心理健康。这就像个性化医疗，针对二十多岁的心理健康。我探讨的一点是，里面有一章叫作“如何思考”，但这其实是关于灾难性思维的。
So when you're faced with uncertainty, the brain's number one go-to is catastrophic thinking. And it's really similar to the brain interpreting uncertainty as danger, right? It's like, oh, my gosh, I'm never going to be happy. I'm never going to find anyone. I'm never going to make friends. you know, what if I die broken alone, that it's going to catastrophize and imagine the worst. And again, that's your brain, you know, trying to protect you. But it's, you know, that's a lot to, a lot of kind of catastrophizing in a 10-year period in your 20s.
所以当面对不确定性时，大脑首当其冲的选择就是灾难性思维。这实际上与大脑将不确定性解释为危险非常相似，对吧？就像，哦，天哪，我永远不会快乐。我永远不会找到任何人。我永远不会交到朋友。你知道，如果我最终一无所有且孤独终老怎么办，它会把事情灾难化并想象最坏的结果。再次强调，那是你的大脑，你知道的，试图保护你。但这是，你知道的，这对于在你二十多岁的这十年里来说，未免有太多的灾难化思维了。
So we really have to work on shifting from that sort of what-if mindset, you know, what if I never figure it out? what if my life goes sideways to what what is or what else and we can talk about that just kind of shifting from fears to facts or from from fears to flexibility so that we can you know not just kind of stay stuck in the fears of what if stuff never works out yeah my can we talk about it because I yeah I read so your team kindly sent me a manuscript of your book and I was I devout it was amazing I was like, oh, great. I feel so lucky. But that was the thing that really stood out to me was this concept of the what is or the
所以我们真的必须努力从那种“如果……怎么办”的心态中转变出来，你知道，如果我永远弄不明白怎么办？如果我的生活急转直下，变成“什么是（what is）”或者“还有什么（what else）”，我们待会儿可以聊聊这个，只需从恐惧转向事实，或者从恐惧转向灵活性，这样我们就可以，你知道的，不仅仅陷于事情永远不会奏效的恐惧之中。是的，我们可以聊聊吗？因为我，是的——我读了，你的团队非常贴心地给我发了你书的手稿，我如饥似渴地读完了。太棒了。我当时想，哦，太棒了。我觉得自己太幸运了。但真正让我眼前一亮的正是这个概念——“什么是（what is）”或者“还有什么（what else）”，因为我以前从未听说过。这确实感觉像是一种非常棒的策略，会让人不禁感叹：哇，为什么以前从来没有人说过这个？把它从——因为我是一个非常喜欢假设“万一”的人，而且我有灾难化倾向。我天生就是一个非常焦虑的人，我总是想，哦，但是如果他们不喜欢我怎么办？如果我建立的一切都被剥夺了怎么办？如果明天我醒来，我家的每一个成员都在空难中丧生了怎么办？诸如此类。
what else because I have not heard of that before. And it does feel like something that is very like, just like one of those strategies where you're like, wow, how come no one ever said this? Like shifting it from like, because I'm such a what if thinker and I'm a catastrophizer. I'm a naturally very anxious person and I always think like, oh, but what if they don't like me? What if everything that I've built gets taken away? What if tomorrow I wake up and every single member of my family has died in a plane accident? Whatever.
总是这样。我发现有时很难打破这种思维方式。感觉一旦我的大脑锁定在最糟糕的情况上，就没有什么能反驳它了。所以你能解释一下这个“还有什么”和“什么是”的理论吗？是的，是的。事实上，我用你之前用过的例子。我的意思是，你刚才并没有完全陷入灾难化，
It's like always that. And I have found it very hard to break out of that thinking sometime. It feels like once my brain is settled on the worst case scenario, there is nothing to disprove it. So can you explain this what else and what is theory? Yeah, yeah. Actually, I'll use the example. you did it earlier. I mean, you weren't quite catastrophizing,
但你说过，我担心我的生活从现在开始只会变得更糟。是的。你知道，当你这么说的时候，因为我说过，数据表明你的生活可能会变得更好，但你却说，
but you said, I worry that my life is just going to get worse from here. Yeah. You know, when you said that, because I've said, well, the data shows that probably your life's going to get better, but you kind of said,
嗯，但如果情况变得更糟呢？当然，这正是，你知道的，二十多岁的成年人的大脑会做的事情。没错。我真是……
well, but what if it gets worse? Which is, of course, what, you know, a 20-something brain is going to do. Exactly. I'm just,
抓到你在灾难化了。是的。所以，这就是你的“万一”。这就是恐惧。万一呢？
I'm way too. Caught you catastrophizing. Yeah. So, so that's your what if. That's the fear. What if? my life actually gets worse instead of better.
我的生活实际上变得更糟而不是更好了。我的意思是，当然，这会是每个人的恐惧。所以转向“什么是”其实有点像我之前对你做的那样。我说，好吧，我的意思是，让我们看看事实。让我们看看数据。你其实说过你现在在二十多岁时已经创造了一个相当不错的生活，对吧？是的，我知道。挺好的。我挺快乐的。
I mean, of course, that would be everybody's fear. So shifting to what is is actually kind of what I did with you about that. I'm like, well, I mean, let's look at the facts. Let's look at the data. You actually said you've built a pretty good life now in your 20s, right? Yeah, I know. It's pretty good. I'm pretty happy.
好的。所以事实是你有——我不知道你生活的全部细节，也不想让你在播客上向我透露这些。但听起来事实是，你已经设法创造了一些美好的东西，即使是在你二十多岁的时候，这非常具有挑战性。对吗？是的。而且我只是觉得所有其他那些东西，比如好朋友、好家人。
Okay. So the facts are that you have, I don't know all the details of your life and not trying to get you to reveal that to me on the podcast. But it sounds like the facts are you've managed to create something good, even in your 20s, which is very challenging. Is that correct? Yeah. And I just think all those other things like good friends, good family.
我有一个我爱的长期伴侣。感觉我好像把每件事都打勾完成了。好的。所以事实是你做到了这一切。那么，为什么你在三十多岁时会完全像……急转直下，然后失去你投入其中的所有技能、诀窍和努力——为什么这一切会凭空消失呢？这太有趣了，因为你对我说这些，而我能清晰地感觉到我大脑中的那些非理性想法无法回答这个问题。但我认为
I've got a long-term partner that I love. It just feels like I've ticked everything off a little bit. Okay. So the facts are you did all that. So why would you completely like go sideways in your, in your 30s and like lose all the all the sort of the skills and the know-how and the work you put into that why would that just go away it's so interesting because you're saying it to me and I can literally feel like irrational thoughts in my brain not be able to answer that question but I think
我总是回想起的，是一种“命运”的感觉，这就像是一种巨大的“冒名顶替综合征”，我认为我们很多二十多岁的人都有这种感觉，就好像：哦，我得到这一切只是因为我很幸运，而好运总会用完的。所以你是把这归功于某些更大的力量，而不是你自己的力量，比起思考你自己的技能、你自己的努力和你自己的劳动，你更倾向于归咎于运气。对。所以我说我审视你的生活，以及我目前对它的了解。我不——我的意思是，关于运气的名言是“智者创造自己的运气”。所以我假设你拥有的大多数东西，你都为之付出了很多努力。这其中可能包含一些运气，但可能包含更多的努力、或刻意经营、或悉心栽培。所以我假设事实是，嗯，你在三十多岁时并不会对这些一无所知。你会继续这样做。所以这有点像从——好吧，我的大脑开始陷入恐惧，但如果我专注于一些事实，并为“什么是”给自己一些肯定，而不是“万一”，而是“什么是”。另一件要做的事，因为有时人们会说：“哦，我没有任何事实。我什么都不知道。这可能走向任何结果。”所以你要去思考“还有什么”。
the thing I always come back to is this like sense of fate this like I think it's like a huge imposter syndrome thing that I think a lot of us in our 20s have where it's like oh I got all this just because I'm lucky and luck runs out. So you're putting it in some bigger things hands rather than your own and like rather than thinking about your own skills and your own effort and your own labor. Right. So I'm saying I look at your life and a little I know about it so far. And I don't, I mean, my saying about luck is a wise man makes his own luck. So I would assume that most of what you have, you've worked for a lot of that. And there's probably some luck involved, but probably even more sort of work or intentionality or care in cultivating that. So I would
那么除了“一切都将急转直下”、“我的生活会变得更糟”之外，我还好对自己说些什么？我的意思是，嗯，这是一种可能性。另一种可能性是什么？你还能说些什么？是的，有趣的是，就好像它可能会保持不变，在这种情况下。
assume for the facts, well, you're just going to, you're not going to know less about that in your 30s. You would keep doing that. So that's kind of shifting from, okay, my brain gets going on the fears, but what if I focus on some facts and I give myself credit for what is, not what if, but what is. The other thing to do, because sometimes people are like, oh, I don't have any facts. I don't know anything. You know, this could go either way. And so you think about the what else.
根据经验，那会很棒，或者它可能会变得更好。我觉得这是一个非常美好的想法。对的。所以只是让你的大脑能够拥有这些，去玩味这些不同的可能性：好吧，你有你的“万一”，但你也有你的“what is（什么是）”和“what else（还有什么）”。我知道——我懂，我并不是第一次和二十多岁的人谈话了。绝对不是。我知道这些并不能消除“万一”的想法，但是，它确实让你的大脑在“我确信我的生活会糟透了”之外，去容纳一些其他的可能性。而且我们不能，你知道，有时候客户会说：“好吧，帮我停止这样做。我想停止这样做。”你永远无法停止这样做，因为从进化上讲，你的大脑需要去想：“哦，天哪，万一呢？”我的意思是，它需要这样做。
So what else could I tell myself besides everything is going to go sideways? My life's going to get worse. I mean, that's, well, that's one possibility. What's another possibility? What else could you be saying? Yeah, it's interesting because it's like it could stay the same in which case. speaking from experience, that would be great or it could get better. And I feel like that's a really nice thought to have. Right. So just letting your brain kind of have these, play with these different
但我得说，随着年龄的增长，你对“什么是”有了更脚踏实地的感觉，它还是会发生，但随后你会想：“哦，管他的，没关系，”或者“我会想办法解决的，”或者“我已经经历过五次了，我还能再应付几次。”——这种心态真的会出现。你会拥有更多关于“什么是”的认知。我真的很高兴听到这些。老实说，你刚才说的最后一点，你已经解决了几次——比如五、六次，或者不管多少次。
possibilities of, okay, you've got your what-ifs, but you've also got your what-is and you've got your what-else. None of that, like I know, I've, you know, this is not my first rodeo talking to a 20-something. No way. I know none of that gets rid of the what-if, but, it does make your brain hold some other possibilities besides like I am sure my life is going to be awful. And like we can't, you know, sometimes clients will say, well, help me stop doing that. I want to stop doing that. You will never stop doing that because evolutionarily your brain needs to go like, oh my gosh, what if? I mean, it needs to do that.
你已经做到了，以前也经历过，所以这变成了一种技能组合，而不是像在我们二十多岁时那样，你知道的，许多重大问题，比如“天哪，我没有交税”或者“我不知道自己在做什么，我刚被解雇了”或者“有人刚和我分手”或者“哦，我的朋友……我觉得很孤独”，这是一个大问题——“我觉得很孤独，我将永远感到孤独”。这就像是我们真正第一次体验到这种感觉，特别是考虑到你有多少重大的，你知道的，你谈到了成人发展，其中的一部分就是社会环境，对吧？你知道，你从一个高度结构化的学校环境转变为靠自己生活，人们搬到各地，工作成为你生活的中心。我记得，为了讲一个关于这方面的个人故事，当我刚二十岁出头、更年轻的时候，我曾经有很严重的孤独感。每当我感到孤独时，我都觉得：“哦，天哪，这种感觉永远不会消失了。这就是我现在的生话。”我是一个孤独的人。直到几个月前，我在旅行时我想：“哦，天哪，每次我离开家都会这样。我觉得：‘我是一个孤独的人。这种感觉永远不会消失’”，我回头去翻阅我以前的日记，发现：“对我来说，这在此时此刻已经是一个相当常规的经历了。这就像是一个周期性的循环。这就像每六个月我就会有这种感觉，也许我应该明白其实它会消失。”所以，我真的很喜欢这个。
But I will say as you get older and you have a more grounded sense of the what is, it does it, but then you're like, oh, whatever, it's fine, or I'll figure it out, or I've figured this out five times before, I can figure it out another couple of times. Like, that actually does happen. You have more what is. I really like hearing that. I honestly, what you said then, the last point you made of, you figure this out a couple of, like, five or six of whatever, 12 times.
“还有什么？”然后还有“什么是？”就像我拥有技能这种心态一样。是的。而且，你知道，你刚才说了很多非常重要的话。其中之一就是你谈到的。在你二十多岁的时候，有太多的“第一次”了。你没有很多“什么是”或者数据点，或者也许你可以回顾一下，“嗯，我在学校、夏令营或运动中挺过了这一关。”但是，你知道，有太多的第一次了。我认为人们觉得他们第一次被解雇时，他们的生活就结束了。但是，你知道，嗯，这里有一个关于你的冷知识：你二十多岁的人到35岁时平均会换9份工作。所以当你经历第3份、第4份或第6份工作时，你就会意识到，好吧，管他的，我会再找一份工作。
You've already, you've done it before, that it just becomes, like, such a skill set rather than feeling like in our 20s, you know, so many of the big problems of like oh my god I didn't pay my taxes or like I don't know what I'm doing I just got fired or somebody just broke up with me or oh a friend of mine like I'm feeling lonely that's a big one like I'm feeling lonely I'm always going to feel this way um it's like the first time that we've really truly experienced that especially because of how many major you know you talked about adult adult development uh and part of that is like social context right you know you you shift from a very structured schooling environment to being on your own and people moving everywhere
我的意思是，你知道，那就是会发生的事情。或者在你经历过三次心碎之后，它依然会痛，因为依恋系统就是这样运作的，但你知道你会挺过去的。而且，你知道，也许甚至会感觉更好，甚至可能会遇到一个更适合你的人。所以随着时间的推移，你积累了更多的数据点，而这正是二十多岁时非常艰难的一点。部分不确定性在于，没有很多数据点来告诉你：“我知道这是什么。我以前经历过。我还会再次挺过去。”但你现在正在积累这些数据点。
and work kind of being the center of your life. And I remember to include like a personal story about this, I used to have such a problem with loneliness when I was in my early 20s when I was younger. And any time I felt lonely, I was like, oh my God, this feeling is never going to go away. This is my life now. I'm a lonely person. And it was only until, probably a few months ago and I was traveling and I was like, oh my God, it happens every time I'm away from home. I'm like, I'm a lonely person. This feeling is never going to go away that I went back and was like looking through old journals of mine being like, this is a pretty routine experience for me at this point. Like this is like on a regular cycle. This is like every six months I'm having this feeling, maybe I should learn that actually it does go away. So I really like that.
所以这正是所有这些第一次、第二次和第三次发生时，你的大脑正在学习的东西。好吧，我能做到。我简直是在听你刚才说的话，然后心里想：“哦，天哪，是的，这勾选了我大脑中的很多框框。”尤其是心碎的那一个也是。就像爱，你感受得是那么深。我确信，我不知道，我不在三十多岁或四十多岁，但在二十多岁时。我记得，分手并不是变得更容易了。只是有一种感觉，它们终究会结束。
What else? And then also what is? Like I do have the skill. kind of mentality. Yes. And, you know, I mean, you said a lot of really important things in there. One is what you were talking about. There are just so many firsts in your 20s. You don't have a lot of what is or data points or, you know, maybe you can draw back on, well, I got through this at, you know, in school or at camp or in sports or whatever. But, you know, there's so many first. I think people feel like the first time they get laid off, you know, their lives are over. But, you know, after, well, here's a factoid for you. Your average 20-something's going to have nine jobs by the age of 35. So by the time you're on job, you know, three or four or six, you realize, okay, whatever, I'll get another job.
这就好像，好吧，你知道，我以前经历过这个。我几乎拥有了一个工具箱，比如这大概会持续这么久。这是第一个月，这是第二个月，这是第六个月，这现在变成了一种常规。而我认为特别是当我20岁或21岁左右的时候，那对我来说简直是世界末日。哦，是的，当然。去过那里，做过那个。我的意思是，我去过那里，不止一次地做过那个。但是，你知道，我认为许多二十多岁的人并不知道分手是导致你在二十多岁时感到抑郁的主要前兆。我的意思是，这完全合情合理，或者说，就像一个重大的依恋损失。所以人们经常会感到
I mean, you know, that's just, that's what will happen. Or after you've had your heartbroken three times, it still hurts because that's how the attachment system works, but you know you will survive it. And, you know, maybe even feel better and maybe even meet someone who's better suited for you. So you have more data points as you go along, and that's just one thing that's really hard in your 20s. It's part of the uncertainty is there aren't a lot of data points to say, I see what this is. I've gotten through it before. I'll get through it again. But you're accruing those now.
在分手后相当沮丧。而且，你知道，我和客户一起探讨的一点是，这并不意味着你是不正常的、有心理障碍的或者生病的。这实际上意味着你的心在工作。你的依恋系统在工作。如果你真的很在乎一个人，真的很爱一个人，甚至可能对他们抱有对未来的设想，如果事情没有成功，你应该感到超级难过。而且我不指望这种难过能在两周内消失。如果有人在经历了对他们来说具有重大意义的关系后说“管他的，来得容易去得快”，我反而会有点担心。所以，你知道，二十多岁的人所经历的一些挣扎，其实其中有很多，
So that's sort of what's happening with all these firsts and seconds and thirds as your brain is learning. Okay, I can do this. I'm literally listening to what you were just saying, being like, oh, my God, yeah, that's checking a lot of boxes in my brain. especially the heartbreak one as well. Like love, you just feel it so deeply. I'm sure, I don't know, I'm not in my 30s or 40s, but in your 20s. I remember, like, it's not that the breakups have gotten easier. It's just that there is a sense of like that they will end in a way.
所以这差不多就是你的大脑在学习过程中经历的各种“第一次”、“第二次”和“第三次”时发生的情况。好的，我能做到这一点。我真的在听你刚才说的话，心想，哦，天哪，是的，这触发了我大脑中的很多共鸣。尤其是关于心碎的那一点。就像爱，你感受得是那么深。我确信，我不知道，我还没到30或40岁，但在20多岁的时候。我记得，并不是说分手变得容易了。只是有了一种感觉，觉得它们总会以某种方式结束。
It's like, okay, you know, I've done this before. I kind of have like a toolkit almost of like this is how long this is probably going to last. these this is the first month this is the second month this is month six like this is this is a routine now whereas i think especially like when i was like 20 or 21 like that was world ending to me um oh yeah of course it's been there yeah been there done that i mean it's it's i've been there done that more than once but um you know i think many 20-somethings don't know that breakups are the kind of leading precursor to feeling depressed in your 20s. I mean, as would make perfect sense or, you know, like a big attachment loss. And so people often feel
就像是，好吧，你知道的，我以前经历过这个。我几乎有了一个工具包，知道这大概会持续多久。这是第一个月，这是第二个月，这是第六个月，就像是，这现在成了一种常规，而我认为尤其是当我20岁或21岁左右的时候，那对当时的我都像是世界末日。嗯，哦，是的，当然，经历过了，是的，经历过，做过了，我的意思是，不止一次地经历过了，但是，你知道的，我认为很多二十几岁的人并不知道，分手是导致你在二十多岁时感到抑郁的主要前兆。我的意思是，这完全合乎情理，或者，你知道的，就像是一次重大的依恋丧失。所以人们经常会感到
quite depressed after a breakup. And, you know, one thing I work with my clients on is that it does not mean that you're abnormal or disordered or sick. It actually means your your heart is working. Your attachment system is working. If you really cared about someone and really love someone, and maybe even envisioned a future with them, you should be super sad if it doesn't work out. And I don't expect that to lift in two weeks. I would be kind of worried if somebody was like, whatever, easy come, easy go after, you know, what felt like a significant relationship to them. So, you know, some of the struggles that 20-somethings go through, well, actually a lot of them,
在分手后感到相当沮丧。而且，你知道的，我和我的客户一起工作时要做的事情之一就是，这并不意味着你不正常、有心理障碍或生病了。这实际上意味着你的心在运作。你的依恋系统在运作。如果你真的在乎某人，真的爱某人，甚至设想过与他们的未来，如果事情没有成功，你应该感到非常难过。我不指望这种悲伤能在两周内消散。如果有人在经历了对他们来说重要的关系后，表现得无所谓、来得容易去得也快，我会有点担心。所以，你知道的，二十几岁的人所经历的一些挣扎，其实有很多，
anxiety at work or sadness after a breakup, this is normal developmental struggle. that actually shows that your brain and your heart are working properly. They're not indications that there's something wrong with you. If you're feeling stressed or anxious about work or you're feeling sad about a breakup, that's what I would expect and hope in a lot of ways. So actually, I want to focus on this a little bit more because there's an example you give in the book. And I'm, am I going to spoil it? I don't know, maybe it's up to you whether.
工作中的焦虑或分手后的悲伤，这是正常的成长发育阶段的挣扎。这实际上表明你的大脑和心灵正在正常运作。它们并不代表你有什么毛病。如果你对工作感到压力或焦虑，或者你为分手感到难过，从很多方面来说，这正是我所预料和希望看到的。所以实际上，我想再多聊聊这一点，因为你在书中举了一个例子。我是不是要剧透了？我不知道，也许这由你决定。
No, no, go for it. Go for it. And I've got her name, or their name. But because of a breakup, she was like, oh, I have an insecure attachment style. I have a disorganized attachment style. Now, that is something that I see all the time. And, you know, I think it's like 65, 70% of us have a secure attachment style. But by the way that we are diagnosing ourselves using TikTok videos and social media,
不，不，尽管说。尽管说。我知道她的名字，或者他们的名字。但因为一次分手，她就觉得，哦，我有不安全型依恋风格。我有混乱型依恋风格。这真的是我经常看到的情况。而且，你知道，我认为大约有65%、70%的人拥有安全型依恋风格。但通过我们使用TikTok视频和社交媒体来给自己诊断的方式，
you would think that all of us are like anxious, avoid it. Right. Anxious ambivalent. Can you talk about that a little bit more? Because it's one of my little secret like pet peeves when it comes to like online psychology. That you mean other people diagnosing themselves with that specifically? Yeah. Or having people be like, you're, you have an insecure attachment style.
你会以为我们所有人都患有焦虑型或回避型依恋。对吧？焦虑矛盾型。你能多谈谈这个吗？因为这可以说是我的一个秘密小癖好，每当涉及网络心理学的时候。你是说特指其他人用这个来给自己诊断？对。或者听到别人对你说：你有不安全型依恋风格。
Yeah. It's having a moment. Yeah. So I'll have people come in new clients and they'll say, you know, I'm getting no of them. Well, I have an insecure attachment style. I'm like, oh, I don't know. Yeah. I'm not so sure.
对。这现在正流行。对。所以我会有新客户来找我，他们会说，你知道，我有很多这种表现。嗯，我有不安全型依恋风格。我就想，哦，我不知道。嗯。我不太确定。
So there's a big difference between having an anxious attachment style and just feeling anxious or having a bit insecure attachment style and just feeling insecure. And I would say that the vast majority of 20-somethings that I work with, they don't have an insecure attachment style. They're in a state of insecurity. So an attachment style is something that you're saying, this is diagnostic and characterological and true of me across all situations, all relationships, all aspects of my life, all ages and stages. No. Like very few 20-somethings of mine would say, yeah, I don't, I'm not
所以，拥有焦虑依恋风格和仅仅感到焦虑之间有着巨大的区别；拥有稍微不安全的依恋风格和仅仅感到不安全之间也是如此。我想说，我共事绝大多数20多岁的年轻人，他们并没有不安全型的依恋风格。他们只是处于一种不安全的状态。依恋风格是指你认为这是诊断性的、性格化的，并且在你所有的处境、所有的关系、你生活的所有方面、所有的年龄和阶段都适用于你的东西。不对。比如，我这里很少有20多岁的年轻人会说，是的，我对朋友不安全。
secure with friends. I'm not secure with my family. I'm not secure with anybody, you know, partners, boyfriends, girlfriends. I mean, that's when you have an insecure attachment style. And if it's been that way consistently across time and across situations. Most 20-somethings for reasons we've already gotten into because of all the uncertainty, they're just feeling insecure. You know, they don't know who their friends are. They don't know if somebody likes them. They don't know if this person wants to go out with them. They don't know if this new relationship's going to work or not. That's just insecurity. That's uncertainty. That is not having insecure attachment style. And I don't love for 20-somethings to, you know, diagnose themselves, not just because they're often not accurate, but they can kind of wrap their identities around this sense of abnormality.
我对家人不安全。我对任何人都不安全，你知道，伴侣、男朋友、女朋友。我的意思是，只有当你拥有不安全型依恋风格时才是这样。而且这种情况在跨越时间和各种情境时都是一致的。大多数20多岁的年轻人，出于我们刚才已经讨论过的原因，因为所有的不确定性，他们只是感到不安全。你知道，他们不知道谁是真正的朋友。他们不知道别人是否喜欢他们。他们不知道这个人是否想和他们约会。他们不知道这段新恋情能否成功。这只是不安全感。这是不确定性。这并不是拥有不安全型依恋风格。我不希望20多岁的年轻人，你知道，给自己下诊断，不仅因为这些诊断往往不准确，而且他们会把自己的身份禁锢在一种不正常的感知周围。
Like, see, I have an insecure attachment style. And if only I had a secure attachment style, maybe this relationship would work or someone would want to be with me. And that's usually not the case. It's just normal to feel nervous. worried and anxious about whether a new relationship's going to last or about, you know, whether someone's going to text you back. That's normal. That's not like an abnormal attachment style.
比如，你看，我有不安全型依恋风格。要是我有安全型依恋风格，也许这段恋情就能成功，或者就会有人愿意和我在一起了。而这通常并不是事实。对一段新恋情能否持久，或者某人是否会回你的信息感到紧张、担忧和焦虑，这都是很正常的。这很正常。这并不是什么不正常的依恋风格。
Yeah, I really like hearing that actually because I feel like there's definitely been points in my life where I've thought that that was who I was. And I really understand what you mean whereby we get really invested in these things being who we are, that anything that contradicts that is us. we deny and we suppress when actually it might be like the gateway to a much more open and better life. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers,
是的，听到这个我真的很高兴，因为我觉得在我的生活中的确有那么几个节点，我曾以为那就是真正的我。我真的能理解你的意思，我们对这些标签深信不疑，认为它们就是我们的全部，以至于任何与此相矛盾的东西都被我们否定和压抑，而实际上，它可能是一扇通往更开放、更美好生活的门户。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神韧性、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的科学。我将与作家、
researchers and other health and fitness experts and more. to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio. app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话。带你超越那些统治着健康产业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上所惊恐的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。节目名称是Two-Per-Cent，在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts，或你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和金小妹到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何在其中生存下来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing, all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊当年的可卡因，只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿线了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病也摆到台面上了。谢谢你把这句话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games.
是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方，收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Games）。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we, are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将结合我在心理健康领域超过十年的经验，与众多不可思议的嘉宾展开对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。但我们却还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要？还是你做个好人只是因为你害怕？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹只是为了做一个好人而做好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023,
加入我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，由我基尔·盖恩斯带你进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和人生目标的真实对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，
former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones.
前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场历时多年的、旨在证明真相的法庭之战。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试结果，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。
It took an army of internet detection. to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
这需要庞大的网络侦探力量来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性：格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我简直惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news out of Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to a love trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，来自马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没完。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听Love Trap播客。
So one of the other big things about our 20s and it's about feeling behind, but it's also about dealing with uncertainty is like how do I know that I'm making the right decisions? I feel like we have so many options of career pathways and people. people we could date and cities we could live in. Something you talk about in the first book, though, that I think really applies here is this concept of sliding versus deciding. Can you talk us through that a little bit more? Yeah. So sliding versus deciding is a concept. I mean, I popularized it putting it in my book, but it's research by Scott Stanley, really about living together, but it could apply to anything. But it's this sense. of like, do we sort of slide into relationships because it happens? It's convenient. It's gradual. We didn't
所以，关于我们20多岁的另一个重大问题是关于落后感，但它也关乎如何应对不确定性，比如我怎么知道自己正在做正确的决定？我觉得我们在职业道路、可以约会的人以及可以居住的城市方面有太多的选择。不过，你在第一本书中谈到的一些内容，我认为非常适用于这里，那就是“顺其自然”与“主动决定”的概念。你能为我们多讲讲这个吗？好的。所以，“顺其自然”与“主动决定”这个概念，我的意思是，我在书中推广了它，但这是斯科特·斯坦利（Scott Stanley）的研究，原本是关于同居的，但它可以适用于任何事情。但这种感觉就是，
really think about it. Or do we really actively decide this is the right person for me? I want to make this commitment or this is the right job. I'm going to stay here another year for these very good reasons. And I think a lot of times, you know, with relationships, whether you're living with someone or even at work, people can kind of slide into sticking around in something because they're already there of well it's just easier to stay another year than to imagine starting over again so i'll just do another year and so we can sort of slide into um living with people being in relationships with people longer than maybe we should be staying with job in jobs longer than maybe it's really serving us because it's the sort of the easier path it's just something we can slide into rather than really saying
我们是不是有点顺其自然地进入了一段关系，因为它就那么发生了？它很方便，是个渐进的过程，我们并没有真正去思考？还是我们真正积极地决定：这就是对我来说合适的人？我想做出这个承诺，或者这是合适的工作。由于这些非常充分的理由，我打算在这里再待一年。我认为很多时候，你知道，在恋爱关系中，无论你是和某人同居还是甚至在工作中，人们有时会因为已经身处其中而顺其自然地继续待在某种环境中，觉得“再待一年，总比想象重新开始要容易，所以我干脆再干一年”。因此我们可能会不知不觉地……和别人同居、维持恋爱关系的时间比我们本来应该的要长，留在某份工作里的时间也比它真正对我们有益的时间要长，因为这是某种更容易的道路。这只是一种我们能顺其自然接受的状态，而不是真正去说：
This is, you know, given all choices, this would be the best one for me. So I guess that leads to my next question is, how do we know which one is the best one for us? Because I feel. Well, that is a good question. I actually think sometimes people slide because they don't want to face the fact that that can't totally be answered. So in my book coming out, you know, any minute, the 20-something treatment, I talk about what are called large. world problems and for large world problems are problems where all the options and the consequences and the outcomes can't be modeled. So like if you know small world problem is you throw dice and you
这就是，你知道的，在所有的选择中，这对我来说是最好的一个。所以我想这引出了我的下一个问题：我们怎么知道哪一个对我们来说才是最好的呢？因为我觉得……嗯，这确实是个好问题。我实际上认为，有时候人们选择顺其自然，是因为他们不想面对这样一个事实：这个问题根本无法给出完美的答案。所以在我的新书《20多岁的治疗》（即将随时面世）中，我谈到了所谓的“宏观世界问题”。宏观世界问题是指那些所有的选项、后果和结果都无法被建模的问题。比如，你知道的，微观世界问题就像你掷骰子，你
can you know bet on the chances of getting a three, you know how likely that is, you know, to get it, not get it. You can even, you know, bet some amount to win or lose. Those are small world problems. Large world problems are choosing a city or a partner or a roommate or a college or a job or how many kids to have. I mean, it's all those problems where you can't model all the options. You can't know all the consequences. So you really, you're making a decision amidst uncertainty, not immense, you know, known factors. So, you know, so many people come to me because they want to know, is it right to stay with this person or to break up or should I take this job or should I take that job? And there is no, I mean, we could talk it to death. You can try to,
可以，你知道的，押注摇出3点的几率，你知道这种可能性有多大，能不能掷出来。你甚至可以，你知道的，押上一定金额来赢或输。这些都是微观世界问题。宏观世界问题则是选择一个城市、一个伴侣、一个室友、一所大学、一份工作，或者生几个孩子。我的意思是，所有这些问题，你都无法对所有的选项进行建模。你无法知道所有的后果。所以你实际上是在充满不确定性的环境中做出决定，而不是在已知的因素中做出决定。所以，你知道，这么多人来找我，是因为他们想知道，和这个人在一起或者分手是对的吗？或者我应该接受这份工作还是那份工作？根本没有，我的意思是，我们可以把这事讨论到死。你可以尝试去，
you know, do an algorithm. You could go see a fortune teller and get your cards read and, you know, but nobody, no one can hack that for you, that it's ultimately really, that's what truly a decision is of, okay, I don't know, I'll never know which one is right or best. So there's not like a right decision. There's just my decisions. So we kind of try to, you know, make the most thoughtful, intentional choice that we can. And then I think you reassess, you know, a year into the job or a year into the relationship and do a real gut check of like, well, how did that choice pan out for me so far? Am I happy, more happy than unhappy? What should I be, you know, kind of paying attention to? And then you decide, well, do I sign up for another
你知道，用算法来算。你可以去找算命先生看塔罗牌，你知道的，但是没有人，没有人能为你抄这个捷径。归根结底，这才是真正的决定：好吧，我不知道，我永远也不会知道哪一个是对的或是最好的。所以根本没有什么“正确的决定”。只有“我的决定”。所以我们尽量去做出最深思熟虑、最有意识的选择。然后我认为你需要重新评估，你知道的，工作满一年后，或者恋爱满一年后，做一个真正的内心检查，看看：到目前为止，这个选择对我的结果如何？我开心吗？快乐多于痛苦吗？我应该，你知道的，注意些什么？然后你再决定，好吧，我是要签下未来一年的合同，
year of this or do I not? That's really interesting. Like you do a gut check. How do you, how do you I like some of those questions you said, like, am I happier than I would be without this person, without this job? Some of the other ways that we can maybe sense dissatisfaction or sense that there might be time to look for something that's better for us. I often ask clients, is there something that you're doing that you hope you're not doing in five years? Or is there something about this relationship that you hope is not the way it is in five years? And if they say yes, then it's like, okay, well, then why are we doing it now? How long are we going to do this now? That usually if people look out five years, like, oh, yeah, definitely don't want to be in this
还是不干了？这真的很有趣。就像是你做一个内心的审视。你是怎么，你是怎么……我挺喜欢你刚才说的那些问题，比如：没有这个人、没有这份工作，我会比现在更快乐吗？我们还能通过其他什么方式去感知不满意，或者感知到也许是时候寻找对我们更好的东西了？我经常问客户：有没有什么事是你正在做的，但你希望五年后自己不要再做了？或者，这段关系里有没有什么地方，是你希望五年后它不要再是现在这个样子的？如果他们回答“有”，那就相当于：好吧，那我们现在为什么要这么做？我们还要这样过多久？通常如果人们展望五年后，就会觉得：“哦，对，我绝对不想在五年后还处于这种死胡同的关系里。”好吧，那我们现在为什么还在这里，还要耗多久？工作也是一样。或者，“天哪，我希望五年后我和我男友不要还在为做饭或者其他什么事争吵。”好吧，那我们今年就把这个问题解决了吧。我经常思考这个问题。我得说，我正处于一段美好的感情中。
dead-in relationship in five years. Okay, well, why are we here now and how much longer are we going to hang out? Or same goes for the job. Or, gosh, I hope my boyfriend and I aren't still having conflict about cooking or whatever in five years. Well, then let's fix it this year. I think about that a lot. I'm, I will say, I'm in a great relationship.
没有……我，我已经问过自己这些问题了，它们的答案从来都指向我们。不过我在之前的感情中，我记得曾有过这种想法：我想和这个人分手，但又没有分。而是想着：让我再等六个月吧，因为我是在拖延痛苦。我在拖延不可避免的事情。然后我有一个朋友对我说，她说：“嗯，比起六个月后才开始，难道你不会更希望在六个月后，你已经熬过这六个月了吗？”她当时说……干得漂亮。是的，我当时就想：“哦，哇，你太……”她说：“反正时间都会过去的。”
There's no, I'm, I've done the questions and they've never, they've always turned in our baby. But I do, in previous relationships, I remember being like, I want to break up with this person, but I don't. But being like, let me just wait six months because I was like delaying the pain. I was delaying the inevitable. And then I had a friend say to me and she was like, well, wouldn't you rather be six months into it? in six months time rather than starting in six months time. She was like, good for her. Yeah, I was like, oh, wow, like you're so, she's like, the time is going to pass anyways.
就像是，你总会到达那个节点。她说：“你迟早都得和这个人分手。区别只在于你是现在就开始这个过程，然后在六个月后说：‘哦，谢天谢地，我早就把这事办妥了’；还是选择等待并拖延。”这就是情感拖延症，你心里其实明白。
Like, you're going to get to the point. She's like, you're going to have to break up with this person. It's just whether you start the process now and then in six months time can be like, oh, thank gosh, I've done that already or whether you weigh and you delay it. And it's like, it's emotional procrastination where you understand. That's true. Yeah, it's like you understand that there's going to be a lot of fallout emotionally and mentally from a big decision. So why not just wait?
确实如此。是的，这就好比你明白，一个重大的决定会在情感和精神上带来很多余波。所以为什么不干脆等一等呢？为什么不把这变成一个“未来的你”要去解决的问题，而你却没有意识到那个“未来的你”很快就会到来？就是你。这最终会变成“现在的你”。是的，说实话。我觉得这挺有意思的，因为我常说这话。我在节目里总是这么说：你可以100%撤销任何决定，唯一的例外是
Why not just make that a future you problem and you don't realize that that future you is going to be there pretty quick. Is you? Is it going to be your present you eventually? Yeah, honestly. And that's like, I feel like it's interesting because I said this to say. I always say this on the show. like you can reverse 100% like the only decisions
那些你根本没有做出的决定。所以我觉得，你知道，好吧，除了生孩子，你可能真的无法撤销那个决定，不过……嗯，你总是可以领养的。对，对，确实如此。但我的意思是，特别是当谈到
you can't reverse the ones that you didn't make. So I think, you know, it's like well I guess having children you can't really reverse that decision but well you can always adopt. Yeah, yeah, that's true. But it's like especially when it comes
职业风险，以及想要搬到新地方、想要去旅行时，不采取行动往往会带来巨大的遗憾，这种遗憾可能比你付诸行动还要多。因为至少，我们要回到你刚才说的话，
to career risks and career risks and wanting to move to a new place wanting to travel you know there is so much regret in inaction, probably more regret than taking action. Because at least again, we're going to return to what you were saying before, like,
当你真正对自己的某种渴望或冲动采取行动时，你就不必再去面对“如果当初我那样做了会怎样”的假设。没错。没错。而且你会从中有所学。但是，你知道，我觉得有时候——虽然这不完全是你刚才谈到的——但往往20多岁的人会推迟做出决定，这样他们就能，你知道，把所有的选项都敞开，不去做决定，这样好像什么都没变……这就好像他们以为自己能按住时间暂停键一样。我的意思是，他们根本无法暂停时间，而不做决定本身就是一个决定。所以你其实是在决定：不和那个伴侣分手，你知道，你其实是在
when you actually do something about a desire or an urge you have, you're not faced with the what if being, what if I'd done that thing. Right. Right. And you learn, you learn something. But, you know, I think sometimes this isn't exactly what you're talking about, but oftentimes 20-somethings will delay decisions so that they, you know, sort of like keep all their options open so they don't make a decision so nothing is like it's like they think they're stopping time i mean they're not stopping time and not making decisions is a decision so you're deciding you know not to break up with that partner you know you were sort of
对它不做决定。这就是一个决定。你是在决定把另外六个月的时间耗在一个你其实已经厌倦的感情里。是的。而且你朋友说得对，她说：“天啊，到这个时候，你本可以已经熬过分手期六个月了。”所以她绝对是对的。这很好。我确实又多待了半年，所以我当时大概应该听她的。不过，人生嘛，就是这样继续下去。当然。不过我很喜欢那种感觉，就是你觉得自己是在为自己争取时间，但时间其实仍然在流逝，对吧？它依然在流逝。我的意思是，我认为成年与上学最不同的地方在于，
not making a decision on it that's a decision you were deciding to sink another six months into a relationship that that you were sort of done with yeah um and your friend was right to say like, shoot, you could be six months through the breakup at this point. So she was definitely right. That's good. And I did stay for another six months, so I probably should have listened to it. But, you know, we live on with it. Absolutely. But I like that idea of like you feel like you're buying yourself time, but like the time is still passing, right? It's still passing. I mean, I think the thing with it's what's so different about being an adult versus sort of being in school is, you know, there's no syllabus.
这里没有教学大纲。没有……这就回到了那个问题：“我是不是落后了？”这里没有教学大纲。没有你必须赶上的时间表。评分系统完全由你说了算。它取决于你的价值观以及你想要实现的目标，而不是取决于别人说你应该怎么做，或者坐在你旁边的人在做什么。你知道，这意味着根本没有绝对的对或错答案。
There's no, I mean, this gets back to am I behind? There's no syllabus. There's no schedule that you have to meet. The grading system is whatever you decide it is. It depends on your value system and what you're trying to achieve, not what other people are saying you should do or what the person sitting next to you is doing. And, you know, that means there aren't any right or wrong answers.
只有你自己的答案。这听起来可能像是一个令人恼火的敷衍回答，但当你真正去接受并践行这一点时，你会发现它其实非常具有解放意义。我不需要担心我做得到底是对是错，是按时完成，还是超前或落后，诸如此类。所有这些其实都不存在。这只是你的人生，你的选择，而且这些选择中的大多数，你一生中都会做出不止一次。我的意思是，即使是在一段可能持续一你生 的亲密关系中，每一天你都在做选择：今天的关系要怎么发展？我要为之付出什么努力？我要和伴侣进行什么样的对话来让关系变得更好？我们一直在不断地改善
There are just your answers, which seems kind of like a, annoying non-answer, but it's actually really liberating when you really lean into that. I don't have to worry about whether I'm doing it right or wrong or on time or ahead or behind, whatever. None of that really exists. It's just, it's your life, your choices, and you're going to make most of these choices more than once. And I mean, even within one relationship that may last your whole life, every day you're choosing, how is that relationship going to go today or what am I going to work on or what's what of what conversation am I going to have with my partner to make it better that we're constantly able to sort of improve the choices that
我们做出的选择。我也很喜欢这一点，这不仅仅是一个决定，而是一个贯穿你一生的主动选择——去留在那里，去维持现状，无论这是一段感情、一份工作还是一个城市，对吧？所以我有最后一个问题要问你。好的。好的，我准备好了。是的。我不知道。我这么说可真是一点都不高潮迭起。不过我觉得你对这个问题一定会有很好的回答。你认为我们在20多岁时应该放下哪些期望，才能让自己变得更快乐？你知道，我觉得你今天在这一点上做得非常出色。我的意思是，我觉得人们最需要放下的最大期望，就是以为自己的20多岁将会是一生中最美好的时光。
we make I like that as well it's like not just a it's not just one decision it's an active choice like throughout your life to be there right to stay there whether that's a relationship a job or city whatever right so I've got one final question for you okay all right I'm ready yeah I don't know That's very anticlimactic of me. Although I do feel like you have a really good answer to this. What do you think is some expectations that we should let go of in our 20s that would make us happier? You know, I feel like you've done a really good job of focusing on that today. I mean, I feel like the biggest expectation that people need to let go of is that their 20s are going to be the best years of their lives.
我们之前也谈过这个。但事实可能并非如此。这其实是个非常非常好的消息。如果20多岁是一生中最美好的时光，那可真是个巨大的打击，因为那样的话，你余下的人生就都在走下坡路了。你可不想那样。这种情况大概率不会发生。但是，你知道，那种认为在20多岁时一切都应该完美无缺的想法，
And we talked about this. but they're probably not going to be. And that's really, really good news. That's a huge bummer of the best years of your lives or your 20s. And then the rest of your life is all downhill. You don't want that. It's not probably going to happen. But, you know, kind of feeling like everything's supposed to be amazing in your 20s
其实是心碎的温床，因为这是一个极具挑战的人生阶段。所以我想说，那种认为一切都会……变得很棒，或者你到30岁时就能把一切都搞清楚的期望，真的应该放下。我在两本书中都反复谈到过一个很酷的研究。我不打算深入探讨细节，但它表明：人生80%最具决定性的时刻都发生在35岁之前。这确实是真的。然而，你知道，其中大部分决定性的时刻都是……断断续续、零星发生的。所以我前几天在Instagram上发了张照片。那是我35岁时的照片，怀着我的第一个孩子，同时拿到了我的博士学位和毕业证书。当时我35岁，我还开玩笑说：“哦，我总算在最后关头把这两样都搞定了。”
is really sort of a recipe for heartbreak because it's a very challenging time. So I would say that expectation that everything is going to. be great and or you're going to have everything figured out by 30. I talk a lot. I really in both books about there's this cool study. I won't get in the weeds about it, but it says 80% of life's most defining moments take place by age 35. That is true. However, you know, most of those defining moments are, you know, happen in fits and starts. So I actually posted something on my Instagram the other day. It was a picture of me at 35, pregnant with my first child and getting my PhD, my diplomas. And that was 35 and I was joking like, ooh, I got these two in right under the
但如果你把这些时间线倒推回去，这两个项目其实都开始得更早。你知道的，我在20多岁的中期就开始为考研而努力学习。我在20多岁的中期第一次偶遇了我的伴侣，然后在20多岁的晚期再次遇到了他，之后我们才结婚。所以，你知道，你其实并不能真正预知这一切——所有这些决定性的时刻，它们大概率会在你35岁之前发生，并且其中一些现在就已经在一点一滴地发生了。只是你没有察觉到而已。所以那种“一切都必须在30岁前尘埃落定”的想法简直荒谬至极。别给自己太大压力。不过，你可能已经开启了其中大部分事情。你只是还没看到自己辛勤劳动的成果罢了。哇。我真的很喜欢这种人生视角。这让事情感觉既非常
wire. But when you follow them backwards, both of those projects started earlier. You know, I started studying to get into grad school, you know, in the middle of my 20s. I bumped into my partner for the first time in my mid-20s and then met him again in my late 20s and then we got married after that. So you know, you don't really know like all these defining moments. They're probably going to happen by the time you're 35 and some of them may be happening in small pieces now. You just don't know it. So the idea that everything is going to be done by 30 is ridiculous. Don't stress. But you might have started most of these things. You just don't get to see the fruits of your labor quite yet. Wow. I really like that outlook. And it just makes things that feel like very
激动人心又充满惊喜。是的。生活既激动人心又充满惊喜。你希望……我不仅希望你的20多岁过得精彩，我也希望你的30多岁、40多岁和50多岁同样精彩。如果你为这些打下了基础，那么生活真的会变得更好。为什么不呢？这是一个多么积极的收尾方式啊。非常感谢你带给我们的这段美妙访谈。现在，我想顺便提一下，你刚刚加入了Instagram，每个人我都加入了，是的。你完成了你的第一次尝试，算是
exciting and surprising. Yeah. Life is exciting and surprising. And you want, you want, I mean, I want your 20s to be awesome, but I also want your 30s and 40s and 50s to be awesome. And I think if you lay the groundwork for that, then life really does get better. Why would it not? What a positive way to finish. Thank you so much for this little little pleasure. Now, I want to quickly say you have just joined Instagram and everyone I did yeah and you've done your first little like you've dipped
涉足了社交媒体。我确实加入了，是的，这挺搞笑的，因为我以前一直是远离社交媒体的。我的意思是，作为一名作家，为了融入大众视野，我远离社交媒体的程度超乎你的想象。我以前没有Instagram。
your toes into social media I have I have yeah that's it's funny because I was off social media I mean to be an author and to be sort of out there I was off social media more than you would expect I didn't have an Instagram
我只有一个极度不活跃的Twitter账号，仅此而已。总之，我基本上是不怎么上网的。我想部分原因是因为我当时专注于写书。你知道的，我有客户，而且，我不知道你是怎么想的，但我认为很多客户可能并不希望看到、在社交媒体上偶遇自己的治疗师。对，我懂。然后发现他们把给你的建议，原封不动地发给所有人。没错，没错。所以对我来说，更多的是，你知道的，我打算保持低调，专心写书。
I had a very inactive Twitter account that was it whatever, I was just sort of off of it. And I think part of it was, I was focused on writing books. You know, I have clients and, you know, I don't know how you feel, but I think a lot of clients maybe don't want to see, bump into their therapist on social media. Yeah, I know. And have them just giving them the same advice they gave you, like, to everyone. Right, right. So for me, it was more of, you know, I'm going to kind of, you know, lie low and write books.
并尝试通过这种方式去触达人们，这对我来说超级重要，因为，你知道的，好的心理治疗既无法轻易获得，也并非人人都能负担得起，实际上绝大多数人其实都负担不起。所以写书的部分目的就是为了把这些知识传播出去。不过，随着社交媒体的发展，随着我被说服——嘿，那才是人们现在获取教育、信息和新闻的地方——如果我想帮助人们，那我也必须出现在那里。我知道你们都不想看我跳舞、化妆或者干别的什么。我想我们并不想看任何人做那种事。
and try to reach people that way, which is super important to me because, you know, and good therapy is not accessible and affordable, not only to everybody, but really not to most people. So part of writing books is about getting that out there. But anyway, as social media has evolved and as I have been convinced that, hello, that is where people get their education and their information and their news now, then if I want to help people, that's where I need to be also. I know y'all don't want to see me dance or put on makeup or anything like that. I think we want to see anyone do that.
好吧，其实，不，这倒也不是真的。不过，你知道的，既然现在感觉显然这就是很多人在获取，你知道的，优质信息的地方，或者他们本可以从这里获取更好的信息，所以我也想成为其中的一部分，成为传播更好信息的一份子。我真的，真的很喜欢这样，因为我觉得你。
Well, actually, no, that's not true. But, you know, now that it feels like, obviously, this is where a lot of people are getting, you know, good information or they could be getting better information. And so I wanted to be a part of that, of the better information. I really, really like that because I feel like you. you will have a lot to contribute. There's lots of misinformation out there, and it's nice to have people online
一定有很多干货可以贡献。外面有很多错误信息，很高兴能有那些拥有学位、对这些东西做过研究的专业人士来到网络上，来真正澄清事实。那么人们可以在哪里关注你呢？你的Instagram账号叫什么？嗯，我是个新人，所以请大家全员出动来支持我吧，因为我只有大概两个粉丝。
who have degrees, have done research on this stuff to really set the facts straight. So where can people follow you? What's your Instagram name? Well, I'm brand news, so please come out in full force because I have like two followers.
不过我在Instagram、TikTok和Twitter上的名字都是Dr. Meg Jay。基本上只要是人们活跃的地方，我的账号名都是Dr. Meg Jay。我是最近才加入的。所以，有些内容……开始上传一些视频了。但我的想法是，特别是在随着《20多岁的治疗》一书的出版，把这些内容传播出去。因为就像你说的，有很多错误信息。我很乐意，你知道的，加入到那场对话中去，去帮助大家。
But I'm at Dr. Meg Jay on Instagram, TikTok, Twitter. pretty much anywhere where people would be, I'm Dr. Meg Jay is the handle. And I've just recently joined. So there's, you know, some stuff starting to put some videos up. But the idea, especially with the 20-something treatment coming out, is to get the content out. Because like you said, there's a lot of misinformation. And I would love to, you know, kind of get in on that conversation and help people out.
噢天哪。好吧，我超级兴奋。我也超级为主持人能读到你的书而感到兴奋。我会在本集简介中留下一个预购链接，还会附上《定义十年》（The Defining Decade）的链接。如果你还没读过那本书，又恰好是这个播客的粉丝，你在等什么呢？这两本书简直太契合了。太疯狂了。
Oh my gosh. Well, I'm super excited. And I'm super excited for people to get their hands on your book. I'm going to leave a pre-order link in the description of this episode and a link to the defining decade. If you haven't read that book and you are a fan of this podcast, what are you doing? They go so hand in hand. It's insane.
对，完全如此。说来也搞笑，我在开始做播客之前甚至还没读过它，然后我开始了这档节目，接着我就想：“噢天哪，这简直太契合了。”所以我会留下……我喜欢这样。是的，我会把这两本的链接都附上。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请
Right, exactly. It's funny. I hadn't even read it before I started the podcast and then I started the show and I was like, oh my gosh, like this is so aligned. So I will leave. I love it. Yeah, I will leave a link to both of those. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please.
随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或者你现在收听节目的任何平台上留下五星好评。如果你认为某个朋友会喜欢这期节目，会从中有所收获，请分享给他们。我确实收获匪浅。如果你有什么节目建议，请随时发送给我：That Psychology Podcast。你也可以在Instagram上关注我：@Gemma Speck，获取更多幕后内容。我们下周会带着另一集节目回归。在此之前，请注意安全，我们很快再见。
feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. Share it with a friend if you think that they would enjoy this. They would get something out of this conversation. I definitely did. And if you have an episode suggestion, please feel free to send it to me at That Psychology Podcast and you could follow me at Gemma Speck on Instagram for some more behind-the-scenes content. We will be back next week with another episode. Until then, stay safe and we will see you soon.
2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神韧性、健身和建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。节目名称是Two-Per-Cent，在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts，或任何你获取播客的地方都可以收听。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever. you get your podcasts.
当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个声名狼藉的骗子时，她们决定自己动手解决问题。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应得的下场。我们总是说
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
相信你的闺蜜。收听《相信闺蜜》（Trust me, babe）。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts，或你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和来说是一个巨大的时刻。
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it, podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图通过我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及我们最喜欢的作家，来理解我们是如何在其中生存下来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。我的意思是，那真是疯狂的一年。
84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year.
我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方，收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本不敢进行的坦诚对话，
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere,
但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套坚不可摧的铠甲？它向世界释放的信号是：你惹不起。仅仅因为你拥有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。
but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
这是一档iHeart播客，保证由真人制作。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
This is an I-Heart podcast Guaranteed Human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个I-Heart播客，保证由人类制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。